birch muesli
traditionally gets made the night before
and left in the fridge i find that a
little bit too heavy and slightly stodgy
so it's the same principles
but a lot lighter
first thing the yoghurt
i think live and raw milk yogurt are
best they're packed with calcium enzymes
and probiotics which help your body
absorb nutrients
it's interesting
because the kids especially would prefer
their muesli with milk but the yoghurt
so much better for them i like making it
literally 10 minutes before i want to
serve it
because it doesn't become stodgy
yogurt in
apple juice that's a great way of
sweetening
the muesli a couple of tablespoons in
give that little mix now
sprinkle in the oats
i like putting two thirds in now to
absorb and almost double in size
and the last third
of oats in at the end
oats are low on the glycemic index which
means they slowly release energy to keep
you going right through to lunch
i quite like it when it just falls off
the spoon
you can see literally in seconds it's
got
thicker
the rest of the oats
in
so i've got different textures
now mix that up
nicely
and it literally takes three or four
minutes to put together
let's get a dry pan on
almonds incredibly healthy toasting them
even better flavor
flake them into the pan lightly toast
them that gives a really nice sort of
crunch to the top of the muesli
[Music]
roll them around the pan so they're
evenly toasted
out into a bowl
the exciting thing about putting your
own music together is that you're in
control blackberries summer raspberries
strawberries
and so it changes berries don't just
taste great they're packed with
antioxidants and vitamins c and k
so just dot the top of your muesli with
your blackberries generous on the
blackberries
sweetness tartness
acidic
and then just sprinkle over
your nice
almonds
i quite like a lot of crunch on top
so be generous
that looks fantastic
perfect way
to start the day
my quick birch and muesli doesn't just
taste incredible it makes you feel
fantastic it's my ultimate healthy
breakfast there really is no better way
to start the day
[Music]
a healthy diet is an important one but
we're pretty relaxed about it my
philosophy is simple try and eat less of
the bad stuff and eat more of the good
stuff and joining me in the kitchen is
my netball nut youngest tilly for dinner
it's amiga rich teriyaki salmon with a
bug wheat soba noodle salad brimming
with healthy greens and a light apparel
spritz jelly for dessert first job the
teriyaki marinade for the salmon tilly
gonna help daddy with the salmon please
right
teriyaki delicious
sticky sweet salmon okay
first of all
i'd like you
a little season on the salmon please
with salt and pepper
thank you
all right i want you to slice the garlic
one in front two behind
yeah
oh oh get a bit faster in the old age
huh
good girl
thank you right garlic in with the
ginger
so we're gonna make a marinade
okay do you know what a marinade is it's
what you cook something in that's right
so let's start off with
soy sauce
three tablespoons
one
good
good three this is rice wine also known
as mirin
one in
i know what that is that's maple syrup
it's a bit like pure gold
beautiful and a little touch of olive
oil
now it smells really good
i want you to rub
the salmon in the marinade if you can
get chance to do this the night before
the salmon actually changes color
but it's fine even with 10 or 15 minutes
before you start cooking it
does it ginger and garlic give it a
different taste
you know what it helps improve the taste
when we cook it have those really nice
glaze on there okay
right let's put that in the fridge to
marinade and we'll start the jellies
to follow the teriyaki salmon a grown up
light dessert prosecco and aperol spritz
jelly
start by soaking gelatine sheets in cold
water
pour prosecco 100 milliliters of water
and cast the sugar into the pan
heat until the sugar is dissolved then
add your gelatin sheets
leave the mixture cool top up with more
prosecco and a dash of the bitter sweet
italian aperol
then pour into tumblers
over orange slices and leave to set in
the fridge
all the refreshment of a spritz in a
perfect jelly form
the teriyaki salmon's marinading time to
get on with the noodle and vitamin pack
veg and seed salad
soba noodles why are they this color
they're this color because they're made
out of
buckwheat
okay and then we're gonna drop them in
so nice and careful if you slide them
that way
and then you go like that in your hand
and that will show you there
and then look
hold them like that and drop them into
the pan okay got them
yeah okay so hold on tight
off you go
nice do they take longer to cook they're
normal
actually take literally five minutes now
what are they
sugar snack please
okay that's so crunchy really crunchy
now
carrot
and kale
i'm gonna show you a really quick way of
slicing carrots ribbons so you just come
down
oh yes it's a bit like peeling them but
that's right off we go there we go
nice big long ribbons
sugar snap peas in yep okay into the
noodles
i forgot two
oh thank you wake up daddy next
kale now you know how good that is for
you right yeah
kale
in right how are the ribbons
okay good oh
that's nice
you you okay like some salt and pepper
on your little cat
[Laughter]
ribbons go in
good girl i didn't forget any like you
did so excuse me
and because we've shaved them really
thinly like this
how long do you think they're gonna take
to cook
about a minute oh it looks so yummy it
does look yummy doesn't it
now we're gonna drain
the noodles
that is beautiful see how the kale's
what happens if you cook um the
vegetables for too long would they just
go a bit hard they'll go soft and mushy
okay
and then
we're gonna drop the noodles
in
but now
i'm gonna make those noodles taste even
better i'd like you to put a little bit
of salt and pepper on there for me
please
next
spring onions through watch your fingers
please
you put a dressing
on there ginger goes in
i can smell that from here you can cut
me
no
what's that a little smell
um sesame seeds oh yeah that's right
sesame oil a touch of sesame oil over
okay
rice wine vinegar
a little splash
okay
and then finally
a little touch
my soy sauce and let you drizzle that in
please
that's it
one little final
ingredient what's that seaweed whose
favorite's that
jacks hollies and mine
slice it into strips
okay
i'm gonna chop that
oh how is that
good i want you to sprinkle that
on top of the
noodles and i'll squeeze the lemon juice
oh excuse me
you also had a lemon shower today
the soba noodle salad is ready now
we'll get on and cook the salmon
oh it looks good doesn't it
boom let's get it
boom right pan nice and hot
what did i show you when you put fish in
the pan which way do you put in
you put it in um
skin down that's right and
then there's the pan there and you put
it in there and you lay away from you if
you lay it towards you what happens it
will spit it yeah splash that's right so
take your time good girl
good girl
and the last one good girl very slicky
very slippery
this one's so fresh nice
nice a nice little bit of ginge on there
now a little bit of garlic it smells of
a mixture of all the flavors doesn't it
so nice color on the salmon
nice and crispy nice and crispy that's
right
and i'd like you to pour
the rest the marinade over for me please
nice
okay
now the sam's gonna glaze now
well done
you're getting good at this cooking
stuff you know that would you like to be
a chef when you grow up yeah really
would you like to have your own
restaurant one day
i'd like to have a bakery a bakery me
and jack we're planning on opening one
together and then we do the paninis and
make the coffees and i do the cakes and
the cookies then it's gonna have like
scrambled eggs for breakfast so you've
already thought this out yeah we were
planning it the other night and when we
couldn't sleep
and who's gonna be the head chef and
who's gonna be the sous chef no we're
not gonna do that because we've both got
different roles in it oh i see this is
well thought out yeah but we're not
going to need anybody else apart from me
and him so no other people that was nice
it sounds amazing
you get the spoon here like this okay
and just tilt the pan i'll tilt the pan
you glaze the salmon for me please
now
there am i darling all right all ready
do you keep the ginger on top of it
what was your favorite type of salmon
when you were little
salmon fish cakes
oh i like those you like those
how does that look it looks delicious
i'd like you to carry that very
carefully over to the table okay and
i'll carry your noodles
ready
let's go well done
so i'm fascinated with this restaurant
you and jack are going to open
yeah
this is my ultimate healthy dinner it's
fresh home-cooked and full of goodness
but most importantly it's absolutely
delicious
[Music]
you